[Music]
i'm brian i haven't declared my major
yet
I guess I'm bipolar in terms of my
interests hi I'm Ben glass and unlike
Brian I'm actually literally bipolar on
a scale from 1 to 100
what do you think your level of
functioning is one I'm bipolar ADHD you
name it I've got it you want to be
ruling you get out my car right now
do you think that college is the best
thing for you right now you need to be
more social I'm going to a strip club
tonight strip clubs are not the best
place to meet this I can't meet a girl
in real life I'm a model every Friday
night you can catch me doing body sushi
so what do you do when you're not
starting fights in public I was
wrongfully kicked out of school and
making a movie to prove my innocence I
make movies too loser
you should get married I'm a scale of 1
to 100
what I think your level of functioning
is 100 it's a delusional plan to make a
movie about this I'm making the movie
I'm making the movie I'm making enough
know you'll make a film I just happen to
be a film producer I know I'll see you
every time I get intimate with a guy
everything goes wrong I just want
somebody to take me seriously where'd
you guys meet outside a strip club that
sounds fun
you're so ordinary to make the feel
brand
[Music]
this is what she does for a living so
see some guys with cash it really
doesn't matter to me thank you for
everything
this night you really want you have to
choose and hunting though
[Music]
you